le soir sur le côté de la nationale 10
vers les essarts le roi
vous pourrez apercevoir de nombreux
camions stationnés les routiers s'arrête
pour manger au restaurant à la grâce de
dieu et passer la nuit
c'est le restaurant le plus proche de la
capitale ça permet s'arrêter là le soir
à 5h 4h et et de repartir le lendemain
matin à 5h et soit traversé paris ou
d'aller faire les livraisons des
premiers clients sur la région
parisienne reprise il y a quatre ans par
nathalie et son mari rui le restaurant
belle cuisine française et portugaise ça
dépend de l'humeur
moi je suis fatigué je suis né en france
donc du coup ça dépend de la météo ça
dépend de plein de choses en ce moment
c'est plutôt grillades donc ça de je
pense que c'est ni français ni portugais
est ce qui ressort le plus de la bouche
des routiers les plus habitués c'est la
convivialité du lieu on compte souvent
des gens à peu près de laon qu'on
n'essaie pas avant et que depuis on
mange avec eux
c'est convivial quoi on s'est lancé dans
ça comme ça à l'aveuglé finalement c'est
un des restaurants de genre de
restaurant que je préférerais le menu du
restaurant fixé à 13 euros ou prend un
buffet d'entrées un plat du jour un
dessert et bien sûr une douche pour les
routiers